all right we're working with the
difference quotient number one we've got
f of X equals 1 over X plus 2 how do we
find the difference quotient we'll
remember f of X plus h minus f of X
divided by H this is our difference
quotient remember subtract is the
difference dividing is the quotient
altogether that's the difference
quotient right and if you take the limit
as h approaches 0 we'll just take it one
step further what you're finding is f
prime of X which is the derivative which
remember the derivative is a formula for
the slope okay at a point so it's the
instantaneous rate of change so for
number one what we're going to do is
we're gonna follow this difference
quotient formula and remember whatever
is in the parenthesis that goes in for X
on the right side of the equation okay
so that's the way functions works we've
got 1 over X plus h plus 2 minus f of X
now f of X is our original equation here
our original function which is the 1
over X plus 2 all divided by H okay so
that's our difference quotient but the
question that students have oftentimes
as well you know where do I go from here
well you can see we've got a complex
fraction meaning we have fractions
within a fraction we have to get rid of
that complex fraction by clearing the
denominators so what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna multiply the numerator by X
plus h plus 2 times X plus 2 in the
denominator by X plus h plus 2 times X
plus 2 now this is like over 1 this is
like over 1 right because you know
anything can be written divided by 1/2
write it as a fraction and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply this to the numerator and this
to the denominator and because we're
dividing by the same thing you know this
quantity here that's like multiplying by
1 it doesn't change the overall value it
just changes the way that it looks so if
we take this and we distribute it to
this first fraction see how the X + H +
2 cancels numerator and denominator and
we're just left with X plus 2 times 1
which is X plus 2 ok - when we
distribute this fraction to this second
fraction here you can see the X plus
twos cancel see numerator and
denominator and we're just left with X
plus h plus 2 now notice I kept that in
parentheses that's important and then in
the denominator we just have h
times this whole quantity x plus h plus
2 times X plus 2 ok so now we're going
to do is we're going to simplify here
I'm going to distribute the negative
okay into the parenthesis so that's
going to give us let's see negative X
minus H minus 2 so that X's are going to
cancel
the twos are gonna cancel because once
positive one is negative and we're left
with negative H in the numerator and you
can see that these H's are gonna cancel
ok so now we're left with is just
negative 1 in the numerator this is your
difference quotient if you're just
simplifying you can leave it that at
that stage right there but if you want
to take it one step further to find the
derivative we would then take the limit
as H approaches zero if we put 0 in for
each that's going to go to zero and you
can see we have X plus 2 times X plus 2
which is negative 1 over X plus 2
squared and that's going to be your
derivative so depending on where you're
at you know with learning about the
difference quotient whether it's finding
the derivative or just stopping at you
know simplifying that difference
quotient you can do it either way okay
number two we've got f of X equals
square root of x minus 3 so same process
working with the difference quotient
whatever is in the parentheses goes in
for X on the right okay so what we have
is we have X plus h now minus 3 minus f
of X so f of X is our original function
here so square root of x minus 3 all
divided by each ok so now what we want
to do is we want to rationalize the
numerator and what we're going to do is
we're going to multiply by the conjugate
so if this was a minus here we're gonna
multiply by the same quantity in the
numerator X plus h minus 3 plus now
square root of x minus 3 whatever you do
to the numerator you want to do the same
thing to the denominator okay if this
was a plus then I would make these -
okay so it's the opposite sign in
between so now we're going to do is
we're going to multiply these together
these two binomials and so you can see
whenever you multiply a square root
times itself you just get the quantity
underneath that square root okay and
then here what happens is the
enter two quantities and the outer two
quantities they're gonna cancel because
see how one is negative and one is
positive so they're gonna cancel each
other out and then the last term times
the last term we've got a square root
times the square root which again
whatever is underneath is what you're
gonna be ending up with and negative
times a positive is a negative
okay so put that in parenthesis all
divided by each times this denominator
so that's X plus h minus three plus
square root of x minus three okay so now
let's see if we distribute this negative
in here we get negative x plus three and
you can see that X's are cancelling the
negative three in the positive three are
cancelling and we're just left with each
in the numerator but notice how that H
and the numerator is going to cancel
with the H and the denominator and we're
just left with one over square root of x
plus h minus three plus square root of x
minus three now you can stop there if
you're just working with the difference
quotient but if you're trying to find
the derivative you want to take that
limit as H approaches zero if I put zero
in for each that's going to cancel that
out and you can see we have square root
of x minus three plus another square
root of x minus 3 which is 1 over 2
times the square root of x minus 3 and
that's your derivative if you want to
take it further you can rationalize by
multiplying the numerator and
denominator by square square root of x
minus 3 but we'll just leave it at that
for right now okay in our third example
f of x equals x squared minus 2x we're
gonna do that same process whatever's in
the parenthesis is going to go in for X
on the right here we've got two x's on
the right so we have to put it in for
both of these X's we're going to get X
plus h squared minus 2 times X plus h
minus f of X now f of X is this original
equation here make sure you put it in
parenthesis okay so you take it as a
group all divided by H okay so now we
want to do is you don't want to just
square both of these terms here you want
to oil this out so X plus h squared is
really like X plus h times another X
plus h right because squared you've got
two of them and then distribute the
negative two negative two X minus 2h
distribute the negative here negative x
squared plus 2x
/ H okay now if we multiply this out
we're gonna get x squared plus 2 HX plus
h squared so notice that HX on the
inside XH on the outside gives us the
middle term - H X okay so now you can
see we've got a negative x squared and
positive x squared those cancel so
you've gotta see what else do we have
here we've got C the 2x and the negative
2x which are cancelling and we're left
with two H X plus h squared - 2 H all
divided by H now notice there's an H and
each one of these terms in the numerator
if we factor it out we get 2x plus h
minus 2 all divided by H now I can see
those HS are cancelling and this is your
difference quotient 2x plus h minus 2
you can leave it like that but if you
want to take it one step further to find
the derivative we take the limit as H
approaches zero so this is going to go
to zero and so now we just have to X
minus 2 and that's your derivative which
remember is a formula for finding the
slope at any point along the curve so if
you want to see more examples with the
difference quotient follow me over to
that video right there
and now we'll do some more examples I'll
see you in the next video